[Musik]
weniger cupid patienten mehr geimpfte
die kritik an der inzidenz als maß aller
dinge wächst litauen baut einen
grenzzaun weil das nachbarland belarus
migranten richtung eu durch lässt auch
mit dem ziel deutschland und letztes
training vor dem großen auftritt morgen
in wembley das em finale england gegen
italien
nachrichten sich das heute mit christian
sievers einen guten samstagabend hinein
und willkommen bei uns um 7 kristin otto
ist auch da und hat den sportlichen teil
dieses nachrichten tages für sie ja viel
los bei uns guten abend die diskussion
in deutschland nimmt an fahrt auf wie
aussagekräftig der reine inzidenz wert
in der aktuellen phase der korona
pandemie noch ist jetzt da immer mehr
geimpft sind und die besonders
verwundbaren deutlich besser geschützt
offiziell steht diese zahl der
neuansteckungen in einer personengruppe
innerhalb eines zeitraums noch im
mittelpunkt gerade bei der frage wo
strengere regeln gelten sollen und wo
gelockert wird
aktuell liegt die sieben tage incidents
bei 5,8 damit ist sie wieder leicht
angestiegen auf niedrigem niveau
allerdings das robert koch institut
meldet 952 neue infektionen innerhalb
eines tages das sind 281 mehr als
vergangenen samstag
außerdem kamen 35 todesfälle dazu das
sind die reinen zahlen jetzt der bericht
von simon pfanzelt zur frage ob diese
inzidenz weiterhin maß aller dinge sein
sollte klinikum stuttgart seit wochen
haben sie auf ihren intensivstationen
kaum noch cupid fälle auch weil sich
aktuell vor allem junge menschen
infizieren
deshalb habe die sieben tage inzidenz
eine andere bedeutung als früher sagt
der klinikchef wir verrühren alle
bevölkerungsgruppen salopp formuliert
und die betrachtung ist eine völlig
unterschiedliche abhängig davon ob die
gefährdeten älteren treiber incident
sind oder ob es sich wie jetzt eher in
jugendlichen und jüngeren altersgruppen
abspielt die sieben tage incidents
bislang die entscheidende größe im kampf
gegen das virus
doch wegen des im fortschritt sage die
inzidenz nicht mehr viel aus über die
tatsächliche gesundheitliche lage so
kritik richtig wäre die krankheitslast
zu müssen also gibt es personen die
hospitalisiert werden die auf die
intensivstation kommen die intubiert
werden also beatmet werden nur die
sterben und diese zahlen muss man sich
viel konkreter anschauen
für viele epidemiologen bleibt die
inzidenz allerdings ein entscheidender
parameter als frühwarnsystem
über den infektionen wenn die hoch gehen
dann bin ich dann eingreifen dann kann
ich tatsächlich ein höheres maß an
schweren verläufen verhindern
als wenn ich erst eingreifen wenn die
intensivstation aufnahmen hoch gehen
auch die gesundheitsämter sehen die
inzidenz weiter als guten gradmesser
die sieben tage instruments ist gut
eingeführt und akzeptiert sie gilt in
deutschland aber auch eu-weit als
maßstab an dem wir uns orientieren
können jetzt ein system zu ändern was
ich gerade integriert hat halte ich für
nicht gut während die debatte um die
inzidenz läuft bereiten sie sich in
stuttgart auf eine mögliche vierte welle
vor hier entstehen gerade 62 neue
intensivbetten im herbst soll alles
fertig sein
großbritannien hat eine um vielfaches
höhere incidents die delta variante hat
sich dort massiv verbreitet besonders
viele sorgen scheint das den
verantwortlichen dort allerdings nicht
zu machen sie planen praktisch aller
beschränkungen aufzuheben
vor dem hintergrund dass ganz england im
fußball taumel steckt eine entscheidung
mit folgen
zum feiern ist es so einfacher für das
virus allerdings auch andreas stamm
man muss die feste feiern wie sie fallen
das erste große finale nach 55 jahren
steht vor der tür england im fußball
rausch und jedem sieht stark die
begeisterung genauso wie die zahl der
korona infektion menschenmassen im
stadion in papst privat feiern überall
in den kommenden wochen wird das bei den
infektionen zu heftigen ausschlägen nach
oben führen und einweisungen ins
krankenhaus werden zunehmen die
regierung rechnet mit 100000
neuinfektionen täglich der noch sollen
am 19 juli alle corona beschränkungen
fallen 50 prozent der bevölkerung seien
doppelt geimpft deshalb würden schwere
verläufe und todesfälle auf relativ
niedrigen niveau bleiben diesen ansatz
erklären 122 forscher in einem offenen
brief für verantwortungslos einer von
fünf neuinfizierten werde an longo witt
leiden auch jüngere und erkranken
millionen werde es wahrscheinlicher dass
eine impfstoff resistente variante
entstehe
dazu kommen weitere probleme
hunderttausende briten werden gerade von
der korona bahn app in zehntägige
selbstisolation geschickt
wird die app massenhaft deaktiviert hohe
fallzahlen alles ist wieder geöffnet
viele werden kontaktiert die regierung
sagt nun wir werden die app weniger
empfindlich machen oder die leute
löschen sie gleich großartig einfach die
alarmfunktion abschalten damit man das
problem ignorieren kann
doch warnungen aller art gehen gerade
unter fußballfeste feiern und öffnen in
der del-tabelle ein experiment der
regierung johnson mit hohem risiko dass
es schief geht
auch in anderen europäischen ländern
treibt delta die neuinfektionen nach
oben die niederlande meldeten zuletzt
sogar ein anstieg um das siebenfache und
das in nur einer woche
die konsequenz die klubs sind wieder zu
bars und restaurants dürfen nur bis
mitternacht offen
in spanien ein ähnliches bild in
katalonien müssen nachtclubs ihre
innenbereiche wieder dichtmachen
und wer nach malta reisen will der
braucht ab mittwoch eine vollständige
corona impfung auf welche krone regeln
urlauber sich im moment einstellen
müssen das können sie jederzeit noch
einmal nachlesen und zwar online in der
zdf- heute- app und damit unser nächstes
thema heute abend für den
bundesfinanzminister war das heute in
venedig ein großer geschichtlicher
moment die 20 wichtigsten
industrieländer haben sich auf neue
globale steuer regeln geeinigt
internationale konzerne sollen eine
mindeststeuer von 15 prozent zahlen
damit sollen steueroasen ausgetrocknet
werden und auch die großen digitalen
unternehmen mehr zur kasse gebeten
werden
es gibt aber noch eine reihe von offenen
fragen andreas postel einen besseren ort
hätte gastgeber italien nicht wählen
können für das treffen der
g-20-finanzminister venedig stieg einst
auf zu ermächtigen see republik durch
kluge handelsabkommen und strategische
partnerschaften und so ist auch hier ein
neuer wind zu spüren mit der neuen us
finanzministerium ist der
multilateralismus zurück die geballte
macht der g-20 verständigt sich auf eine
globale mindeststeuer deutschlands
finanzminister olaf scholz spricht
im historischen moment ein moment bei
dem eine hundertjährige praxis der
internationalen besteuerung von
unternehmen geändert wird
die g 20 staaten haben sich jetzt hier
darauf verständigt dass sie ein neues
eine neuordnung der internationalen
besteuerung miteinander vereinbaren
wollen
künftig soll eine globale mindeststeuer
entrichtet werden in höhe von 15 prozent
auf sämtliche unternehmensgewinne
weltweit das heißt wenn beispielsweise
ein deutsches unternehmen im ausland
etwa in den niederlanden nur ein prozent
steuern auf seine gewinne entrichtet
fordert der deutsche fiskus die
restlichen 14 prozent ein
gewinne verschieben in steueroasen würde
unattraktiv das bringe vor allem von den
globalen digital konzernen 100
milliarden euro weltweit für deutschland
etwa ein bis anderthalb milliarden
schätzen experten
doch bis es soweit ist sind noch einige
hürden zu nehmen
in europa ist sicherlich die größte
hürde dass wir selber einige steueroasen
haben irland zum beispiel russland oder
ungarn und die wehren sich noch gegen
diese steuerreform international ist es
so dass in den usa die parlamentarische
mehrheit für ein solches vorhaben auch
noch nicht gesichert ist
ungeachtet der unterschiedlichsten
proteste die globale mindeststeuer werde
auf den großen g 20 gipfel der staats
und regierungschefs ende oktober in rom
wohl endgültig verabschiedet weitere
verstörende nachrichten jetzt aus dem
belarus offenbar als reaktion auf die
eu-sanktionen gegen sein regime schloss
der belarussische machthaber alexander
lukaschenko jetzt hunderte flüchtlinge
aus dem nahen osten und afrika gezielt
über die grenze nach europa so wirft ihm
dass die litauische regierung vor das
ziel der menschen vor allem deutschland
von belarus kommen die migranten nach
litauen und damit in die eu das land
zieht jetzt die reißleine und schließt
seine eu außengrenze zu belarus die
ersten stacheldrahtzäune stehen schon
natalie steger berichtet
unterwegs mit dem litauischen
grenzschutz an der grenze zu wählerisch
denn praktisch täglich kommen gruppen
illegaler migranten aus dem nahen osten
und afrika
via belarus nach litauen und damit in
die eu anfangs tauchten sie nachts auf
dann auch tagsüber und jetzt zu jeder
tageszeit es geht nonstop mehr als 1500
migranten haben sie registriert dieses
jahr 2020 waren es noch insgesamt 81 die
meisten stellen asylanträge doch die
prüfverfahren sind nicht einfach denn
oft ist die identität der geflüchteten
unklar
die grenzschützer suchen auf der
flüchtlings route durchs hohe gras
hinweise sie werfen sehr viel weg schuhe
papiere dokumente flugtickets wir
versuchen herauszufinden wer sie sind
und wie sie hergekommen sind mit an bord
jetzt einen grenzzaun laut litauen
spielerisch gezielt illegale migranten
vor allem aus syrien und irak der
belarussische machthaber lukaschenko hat
mehrfach gedroht migranten durchzulassen
eine retourkutsche wegen der
eu-sanktionen belarus erlaubt den
migranten nicht zufällig die grenze zu
übertreten was passiert ist ein
bewusstes mittel von politischer
manipulation
migranten würden per direktflug nach
belarus geholt so litauen und dann
weitergeschickt die grenzsicherung ist
keine einfache mission denn die grenze
zu belarus ist fast 680 kilometer nach
deutschland zum ersten mal hat ein
landkreis in deutschland wegen eines
hacker-angriffs den katastrophenfall
ausgerufen
kriminelle haben am dienstag das
computersystem des kreises anhalt
bitterfeld in sachsen-anhalt attackiert
jetzt können zum beispiel keine sozial
und unterhaltsleistungen mehr ausgezahlt
werden das bundesamt für sicherheit in
der informationstechnik ist
eingeschaltet die kommunale
infrastruktur gilt als besonders
schlecht gegen cyber angriffe geschützt
und wir bleiben noch in sachsen anhalt
gehen in die politik dort es wäre ein
bündnis mit seltenheitswert eine schwarz
rot gelbe deutschland koalition könnte
im herbst die nächste regierung in
magdeburg bilden
wochenlang wurde sondiert bevor aber die
koalitionsgespräche starten können will
vor allem die spd noch beraten was die
führungsgremien der partei empfehlen
darüber berichtet andreas weise treffen
von landesvorstand und parteirat der
sachsen-anhaltischen spd in quedlinburg
fünf stunden diskussion hinter
verschlossenen türen dann aber ein
deutliches ergebnis der parteirat und
der landesvorstand geben die empfehlung
koalitionsverhandlungen mit cdu und fdp
aufzunehmen wir haben uns das nicht
leicht gemacht am mittwoch ende der
sondierungsgespräche mit cdu und fdp es
soll ein neues dreierbündnis für sachsen
einheit geben wir sind im moment bei
einer guten basis mehr haben wir noch
nicht jetzt müssen wir in die gremien
gehen aber ich habe ein sehr gutes
gefühl
die fdp wollte anfangs gar nicht
mitmachen haben doch cdu und spd
zusammen eine stimme mehrheit im landtag
doch jamaika gespräche mit den grünen
verliefen schnell im sand wir haben in
den letzten drei wochen gemerkt dass
eine koalition aus cdu spd und fdp sehr
viel für das land bewirken kann
spd und cdu haben beide sehr deutlich
kommuniziert dass sie eine stabile
mehrheit haben wollen
vor allem ministerpräsident haseloff von
der cdu drängt auf eine stabilere
mehrheit als eine mit nur einer stimme
kleine grabenkämpfe sind da nicht mehr
wichtig denn die koalition ihre mehrheit
werden davon nicht gefährdet auch nicht
von krankheitsfällen das heißt die
mehrheit ist sicher zweitens jeder von
den beiden kleineren partnern ist
entbehrlich das heißt auch die beiden
kleineren partner haben keine
erpressungs position mehr
am freitag muss noch ein spd
landesparteitag der aufnahme von
koalitionsverhandlungen zustimmen
spätestens mitte september soll es dann
eine neue landesregierung geben
esther bejarano überlebte den holocaust
und hat ihr leben danach dem kampf gegen
das vergessen gewidmet gegen rassismus
und antisemitismus heute ist sie
gestorben
gescheraner hat ihre erinnerungen auch
aufgeschrieben hat die zeit im
mädchenorchester des vernichtungslagers
auschwitz zu ihren jungen zuhörern sagte
sie immer ihr seid nicht schuld an
dieser schrecklichen zeit aber ihr macht
euch schuldig wenn ihr nichts über die
geschichte wissen
erster bei serrano wurde 96 jahre alt
der nachruf jetzt von ralf zimmermann
von siewert ihre befreiung im mai 45 hat
esther bejarano zeitlebens als ihren
zweiten geburtstag bezeichnet bis
zuletzt hier vor gut zwei monaten hat
die auschwitz-überlebende deshalb dafür
gekämpft dass der 8 mai ein feiertag
wird in deutschland dieser tag ist ein
historischer tag weil damals haben
amerikaner und russen sich umarmt und
geküsst und haben geschrien nie wieder
faschismus nie wieder krieg auschwitz
hat esther bejarano wohl nur überlebt
weil sie akkordeon spielte im
mädchenorchester die todeslager der
nazis wurden zu ihrem lebenstraum die
musik zu ihrem lebensretter dafür da
stehen mussten und musik machen mussten
und die leute uns zugewunken haben in
den zügen und gedacht haben wo es sowohl
musik spielt da kann es ja nicht so
schlimm sein
das war für uns es das schlimmste
schon hoch betagt hatte sie mit der
rapper gruppe microphone mafia noch
musikalisch front gemacht gegen rechts
und rechtsextremismus
[Musik]
und konnte nicht fassen dass jüdische
einrichtungen in deutschland unserer
tage von der polizei geschützt werden
müssen
ich möchte nicht dass nochmal so etwas
passiert wie damals nie wieder und wir
haben da eine verpflichtung
sie war eine kämpferin noch mit 96 und
sie wird vielen als mahnende stimme das
wetter in deutschland da blitzt es
donnert es regnet es mit folgen große
überschwemmungen nach tagelangem
dauerregen wie hier in franken
die feuerwehr kommt kaum hinterher mit
dem keller auspumpen mehrere regionen
riefen den katastrophenfall aus
das ist keine gute nachricht wenn die
meteorologen für die kommenden tage
neuen regen voraussagen mehr zum wetter
gleich erstmal ein hammer
sportwochenende christin das tut richtig
gut auf geht's nach vier jahrzehnten
kommt die wimbledon-gewinner reden mal
wieder aus australien ashley partie
erfüllt sich auf dem heiligen rasen
ihren kindheitstraum und kann ihren
triumph nach drei sätzen gegen karolina
pliskova aus tschechien kaum fassen
echte party überwältigt die
weltranglisten-erste zum ersten mal
wimbledon siegerin ihre technische
herausforderung karolina pliskova trotz
dir einen satz ab in den entscheidenden
momenten aber spielt party ihr enormes
repertoire aus 6 2 3 6 7 und 6 3
die halbfinal bezwingerin von angelique
kerber mit dem ersten wimbledonsieg
einer australierin
seit evonne goolagong vor 41 jahren
und parallel in hamburg gelingt andrea
petkovic eine überraschung die
33-jährige sichert sich im deutschen
duell gegen julia niemeyer ebenfalls
nach drei sätzen den finaleinzug ihren
ersten auf der wta tour seit sechs
jahren
dort wartet morgen die rumänin elena
gabriela rose italien oder england wer
wird morgen abend fußball-europameister
live zu sehen hier bei uns im zdf einen
klaren favoriten gibt es nicht
allerdings den heim vorteil der briten
erneut in wembley
die erwartungen an englands mannschaft
enorm aber von drucks aber keine spur
den protagonisten gleich das lächeln
beim abschlusstraining nicht aus dem
gesicht
jetzt geht es um die farbe der medaille
so eine gelegenheit bekommst du selten
in deiner karriere
beide teams dank eines elfmeters im
finale england glücklich durch den in
der verlängerung gegen dänemark italien
cool mit junior im elfmeterschießen
gegen spanien alles reine nervensache
ohne heißes herz und kühlem kopf
gewinnst du kein endspiel in wembley
gegen england werde die paarung ein
klassiker aber noch nie in einem finale
italien oder england schreibt morgen
eine besondere geschichte an eine
umfassende einstimmung auf die em auf
das finale gibt's von 23 uhr an dem
aktuellen sportstudio außerdem zu gast
surflegende robby risch und dann noch
zur tour de france vierzehnter etappe
der auftakt in den pyrenäen mit einem
erfolgreichen ausreise der niederländer
bauke mollema feiert nach einer 42
kilometer langen alleinfahrt den
tagessieg mit gut einer minute vorsprung
auf patrick konrad aus österreich an der
spitze der gesamtwertung bleibt alles
unverändert und morgen dann ein kurzer
abstecher nach andorra christian so
jetzt gibt es noch eine geburtstagsfeier
im berliner zoo denn panda dame mengen
wird acht ganz zur freude von pit und
paule ihren jungen
die tierpfleger haben aufgetischt es
gibt eine sommerliche eistorte aus
gemüse und früchten erst mal ausgiebig
begutachten und dann ist die acht
verputzt
eine echte panda party
dieser sommer bleibt gewittrig auch wenn
sie morgen im nordosten und südwesten
durchaus chancen auf sonne haben details
beim wetter gleich von katja honnefer
ich empfehle ihnen natürlich das heute
journal mit der kollegin bettina
schausten um 22 uhr 45 und sage danke
für ihr interesse
bis morgen wenn sie mögen und jetzt vom
gesamten team hier in allen ein
angenehmes
[Musik]
guten abend platz da jetzt kommt es
scheint dieses tief zu sagen dass ich
bis anfang nächster woche über
frankreich einnistet so muss das kleine
hoch dass uns morgen im südwesten beehrt
richtung ostsee abziehen und das tief
das uns morgen schauer und gewitter
bringt nimmt kurs auf norwegen das
gewittertief allerdings über frankreich
bringt uns dann anfang der kommenden
woche hitze in den nordosten
deutschlands
heute gab es erstmal viel nebel in
bayern aber auch hier im donautal der
löste sich im laufe des tages auf dann
war es freundlich die schon daraus
gezogen ab aber vom besten kamen schon
dichte wolken heran und diese dichten
wolken werden uns auch in der nacht
beschäftigen da wird das kräftig regnen
und an den alpen sind auch gewitter
dabei
diese schauer und gewitter ziehen morgen
über tage langsam weiter nach nordosten
am längsten freundlich bleibt es hier
zwischen dem streber und der ostsee und
besonders am nachmittag lockern die
wolken im südwesten auf im nordosten
wird es morgen am wärmsten mit
höchsttemperaturen von 26 bis 28 grad
sonst werden 20 bis 25 grad erreicht und
am montag kommt dann von westen diese
gewitter luft heran dann verschärfen
sich die temperaturgegensätze im
nordosten ist es heiss im südwesten
kühlen und das verstärkt auch die
gewittergefahr guten abend